I used to live my life a quarter mile at
a time but things changed our Father now
I will always be in your heart
little Brian I have a gift for you
your daddy gave me this no I'm gonna
give it to you
it's very special it's for protection
from what's coming all right down what's
next no matter how fast you walk
to be compared to you knowin are
unsurpassed
your tummy and mine just caught up to me
there's a long time don't so we're up
against a master thief high-performance
driver
whoo easy
[Music]
Jacob is Dom's brother your whole life
you pushed yourself to be faster than
Donna smarter than God stronger than Tom
but could you kill him
[Music]
because I'm ready if you are
[Music]
there's nothing more powerful than the
love of family you turn that into anger
there's nothing more dangerous maybe
this is the end but we won't go out
together you know I'd ride to the death
with you
[Music]
let's get to work please tell me that's
not a Pontiac Fiero strapped to a rocket
engine impressive I no no no that's
that's not in for us
I came here to take you down a little
god that's your mistake
this is my world
damn they got a magnet plane hold on
tell me you're not thinking what I think
you're thinking there's no bread
oh hell not
[Music]
hey guys surprise
nice Clubhouse
[Music]